if I showed you Terrence Malick's most
recent film song to song alongside his
debut film Badlands shot 44 years
earlier they would seem dramatically
different much of what seems to make up
the look and feel of Malik's newer work
is the unique cinematography developed
in collaboration with Emmanuel Lubezki
Malik's director of photography since
the new world the free-flowing
cinematography fits the non-traditional
approach to narrative and it's one of
the most interesting most expressive
uses of wide-angle lenses I've ever seen
in film but if we look closely at
Badlands and everything that follows
will find many clues that will help us
uncover what motivates the stories Malik
chooses to tell and how he chooses to
tell them the directors before series is
sponsored by movie go to movie comm /
thomas flight to get your free trial
today Badlands is an impressive debut
film Malik has a clear artistic vision
from the very start
Badlands tells the story of 25 year old
Kitts killing spree and 15 year old
Holly as she unquestioningly accompanies
him
little did I realize that what began in
the alleys and back ways of this quiet
town would end in the Badlands of
Montana's from the very start we can see
a unique approach to story forming
[Music]
what's your name I said my Hawley
where are you from Chicago
[Music]
I think perhaps the most significant
element of Malik's style is his focus on
the interior landscape of the characters
his films concern themselves with what
the characters are thinking and feeling
this comes before any consideration of
specific plot details
I think his entire approach to
filmmaking is structured around
communicating that internal landscape
one of the tools he uses to do that one
that features as an important part of
Badlands and every one of his films
since then his voice over the world was
like a faraway planet to which I could
never return I thought what a fine place
it was full of things that people can
look into and enjoy my opinion can't
nothing make you forget it
each time you start from scratch what
voice is this that speaks within me when
did you first touch my heart they guide
you on your way I tried to be kind it
only made me colder
while use of voiceover in film is often
criticized as a crutch for bad writing
Malick's use of voiceover serves to
accompany more than to restate plot
characters are often using or observing
and you get the feeling that the
voice-over is almost more for the
character than it is for the audience
Malik's approach to voiceover is similar
to his approach to cinematography he's
there to observe not construct
[Music]
this interior landscape is naturally
subjective and it's reinforced by the
perspective of the narrative Malick's
stays with the characters that the story
focuses on rarely zooming out to a
broader perspective to inform the
audience the audience gets to know what
the characters know or care about and do
but not much more you're there with them
and rarely do we even get a wide shot or
an establishing shot to crown the
character within the world rather the
focus is on the characters subjective
experience of the environment around
them
the one time in badlands where we do get
a bird's-eye view perspective of what's
happening away from the protagonists
it's cast in an oddly stylized
black-and-white montage almost as if
we're seeing from Holly's perspective in
the future how she imagined things
happened in the past and this
subjectivity is I think what leads to
Malik's emphasis on nature and
environment as a part of this
storytelling this will become a much
heavier focus and play a larger role in
later films but it's very present in
badlands the film's title itself speaks
to this approach to filmmaking after the
characters experience the environment is
the next focus again taking priority
over plot and narrative the film's don't
emphasize locations rather they try to
exist within a larger environment
instead of interior coffee-shop day we
get open skies flowing rivers and vast
landscapes of skyscrapers
and this environment is one that
includes animal life Malick's inclusion
of and focus on the animals that
incidentally surround his characters is
very unique in the narrative film world
I think the inclusion of these seemingly
irrelevant details is part of what
creates the immediacy and subjectivity
of the perspective in our lives in the
present we often don't yet know which
details are relevant to our story it's
only in hindsight that we can exclude
everything extraneous to the story we'd
like to tell
[Music]
Malak often handles what plot does exist
in a very loose sense plot only exists
in his films primarily as an accessory
to the characters journey while Badlands
is perhaps his most plot heavy film we
still catch a glimpse of how Malek will
work in the future in how he treats the
plot in badlands one of those glimpses
is how he shows story through montage
instead of a traditional scene structure
we get sections where he uses a montage
of moments along with music and
voiceover he continues to expand his use
of this technique throughout his career
with some of his later films existing
almost entirely in this mode besides a
change in cinematography the other
change in Malik's style that led to
where he is now is in the editing it
won't be until the new world that will
see the type of scenes that represent
what I think of now when I think of
Malik's work greed Envy slander and
forgiveness have never been heard
[Music]
they have no Genesee no sense of
possession but all the ingredients for
seems like that one music voiceover and
montage are present in his earlier films
and in badlands the forest the coup and
other doves and the Hama dragon flies in
the air made it always seemed lonesome
like everybody's dead and gone when the
leaves rustled over here it was like the
spirits were whispering about all the
little things that bothered him it would
just take some additional
experimentation and freedom in the
editing room to bring it to its fullest
form
finally in badlands we can see Malik's
preference for naturalistic lighting
Badlands features many scenes shot
during Golden Hour the hours surrounding
sunrise and sunset and he will go on to
shoot some of his later films almost
entirely during this time of day with
Badlands Malick showed an immediate
competence and a grasp of more
conventional filmmaking his career since
then has become progressively more
experimental like Wes Anderson the first
director I talked about in this series
terrence malick is a great example of
how small elements of a director style
can evolve into something more
pronounced and obvious throughout their
career but also like Wes we can see how
the more fundamental elements of what
motivates Malick style were present even
before the obvious visual
characteristics emerged this series is
made possible by movie movie.com is a
cinema streaming and download service
they have 30 movies streaming at a time
every day one is added and one is taken
away movies strength is in its curation
it gets me to watch a lot of interesting
international and indie films that I
wouldn't have found otherwise if you're
a fan of Malick's films movie will
definitely have some things to watch
that are right up your alley
I could keep trying to convince you why
it's great you really have no excuse not
to see for yourself
you can try movie for free for 30 days
at MU bi dot com
Thomas flight that's mu b.com slash
Thomas flight for your extended free
trial thanks so much for watching I'll
link to the other videos in this series
on the top I also want to thank Tom from
like stories of all for the notes he
gave me on this video he's made some
other great videos and about terrence
malick so i'll link to a playlist of his
and my videos about malik on the bottom
also thank you to my patrons go to
patreon.com/scishow
[Music]